[Applaudissements]
gérard si vous trouvez vétérinaires dont
j'imagine je vois se clame donc comme
ils s'appellent si nous ne ferons pas où
passer à cyril féraud si c'est cyril
féraud et bien vous participerez slam
ils feront à ces dames copains d'accords
pas le voile à ce monsieur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et c'est parti pour le slam on applaudit
la reprise qui est à vos côtés bonjour à
vous qu'est ce que vous faites dans la
vie je suis professeur de zumba voilà
comment on fait je suis alors bon dessus
mais pas pour leur venir vous avez un
air des nuages ou de cyril hanouna
n'entre pas soit pas le public
un petit air je sais pas moi j'y peux
rien vous ouvrirez il ya pire comme ça
c'est dit que je suis moche et ça va
plus vite des lettres manque deux fois
pour avoir de l'appétit de l'appétit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vous ai connu geoffrey il en fait je
suis quasi persuadé que vous êtes cyril
hanouna mais j'ai juste un truc qui me
dérange c'est qu'il est pas comme ça
normalement
moi je suis désolée la remise pour nous
faire un câlin oui il faut bien je peux
aller au début j'ai cru que c'était une
perruque
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]